[Music]
oscar-winner Jennifer Lawrence she just
got one to scare during an emergency
landing when the plane she was flying in
lost both engines
travel either close 15 Saturday Jennifer
took off in a private jet from
Louisville Kentucky and wrapped at
Teterboro Airport in New Jersey after
the jet climbed to 31,000 feet the left
engine failed and the pilot declared an
emergency who plane was then diverted to
Buffalo Niagara International Airport
the control tower put out a warning that
emergency uh about a mile final
emergency crews were standing by on the
runway but as the jet attempted to land
its second engine failed the FAA tells
ET the aircraft did land safely and it
is investigating I'm not the best flier
j-law who is okay and her co-star from
the movie passengers Chris Pratt told us
about another scare just six months ago
we hit a little turbulence and then
she's Kirby darted shouting we were
heading towards the earth know there
were gonna be no survivors she was like
pilots pilots pilots I prefer you
freaked me out he's like they're
focusing goes like why am i focusing on
yeah focusing what do they need to focus
you think Jennifer would want to take
the train next time but we are so glad
that everybody is safe Jennifer was
leaving Kentucky after spending time
with family this weekend
[Music]
you